[Music]
hello and welcome to i' like to know my
name is CA Murray and it is my privilege
and my pleasure to welcome you to our
Bible question and answer program uh
which is our sort of kid in the candy
shop program because we like to study
the word of God we like to hear what's
going on in each other's minds as we
study the word of God we don't study
together but every time you study the
word of God it brings you together so
I'm in the company of our president and
founder Steven bour Pastor good to have
you here good to see you and have you
back CA good to be back very good to be
back uh as we said this is our one of
our favorite programs the time goes very
very quickly because when you're in the
word of God you're having fun and when
you're having fun the time goes so very
very fast may I encourage you to join us
by sending in your Bible related
questions to tvom tv.org that's TVM
tv.org and uh you can participate um and
send in your Bible questions and we will
promise you that we will answer those
questions from the word of God as best
God gives us the ability to do so and uh
we'll have a good time doing just that
um Pastor maybe we should go into our
word of prayer and then launch out
because we've got several questions and
um uh we're ready to get at it this is a
little pile from the great big pile that
we have we need more than a half an hour
but anyway let's get into it by having a
word prayer Father in heaven we thank
you now for the privilege of opening
your word and answering some questions
that have been sent to us uh very
important questions and we just ask for
the guidance of your Holy Spirit uh give
us Clarity of thought give us the words
that we need to speak and I ask Lord
that you will bless all of those that
have sent in questions I know many
individuals are suffering in this time
when we're kind of winding down on the
pandemic we just ask that you'll be with
them and give them encouragement and
bless us as we study we pray in Jesus
name amen amen amen and amen uh we do
have uh fairly impressive pile of
questions of which we have selected just
a few um this one uh is a question you
know sometimes you get very serious
questions sometimes you get questions
that are a little lighter uh sometimes
you get some that are in the middle um
but this question is in the parable of
the tears can the tears be be converted
to become wheat uh parentheses good seed
through the preaching of the Gospel can
The Good Seed also be corrupted through
the negative influence of the world or
good seeds wheat remain good seeds while
tears Bad Seeds remain
tears interesting question yeah first
time I've ever heard that question yeah
I've not heard it's it's parallel uh in
any place what's interesting Pastor uh
before you you you go into
that what what popped into my mind when
I when I read this was that they are
actually conflating two different
Parables they are both found in Matthew
13 one is the parable of the swer who
planted and came back and there were
weeds right the second one is the
parable of uh uh The Good Seed being
being being uh scattered among different
sorts of soil rocky soil dry soil that
kind of thing they're both there in
Matthew 13 uh but the the points of the
parables are not quite the same other
words they're driving at two different
points right I think the the central
idea of this person even though uh this
person is conflating yes those two
Parables uh is whether uh tears can
become wheat and wheat can become tears
yes and uh you know I think that we need
to referred to the parable of the sewer
MH uh where you have four different
soils with one kind of seed yes is the
word of God MH and um you know if people
could not change the soil upon which the
word uh Falls why would Jesus even tell
the parable precisely you Jesus is
telling the parable because he wants
people uh you know if they have a rocky
soil get with it and become good soil
you know if they're if they're by the
wayside you know don't be by the wayside
anymore yes yes so so I think that
that's the gist of it obviously uh
people who are tears that is before the
judgment of course uh people who are
tears they certainly by accepting Christ
uh can become wheat yes yes the the good
thing is you know um God gives us the
power to become to become Sons and
Daughters of God if we could not change
how sad we would be if we were stuck in
uh the way we were 20 years ago 10 years
ago 5 years ago yesterday uh the fact
that uh we can hear and obey and change
is is given uh to us as an understanding
of the power of the Gospel that the
gospel can change lives um the other
Parable uh about the sore uh I think the
burden for that particular one is don't
you try to determine what's good and
what's bad who's good and who's bad let
God do that you're going to have good in
the church you're going to have bad in
the church until Christ comes but let
Christ do that sifting and sorting don't
you try to do it because in your si and
sorting and pulling you're going to end
up pulling up some good uh uh uh uh
right uh I'm going say fruit but you're
going to pull up some good some good
with the tears so don't you do that uh
let God do that that's God's job not
ours you know uh Ezekiel Ezekiel chapter
36 uh has some very comforting words uh
verses 26 and 27 which clearly
show that even if you have a Stony heart
the Lord can do the surgery he can take
off the Stony heart and give you a heart
of Flesh so uh if tears that is before
the close of probation yes if tears
repent and they receive Christ and
Christ enters their life yes well that
would be like a Stony heart being taken
taken out very true uh so do you want to
read the uh Ezekiel 36 and vers 26 and
27 okay we find those very comforting
words you know that it is possible to
have a Heart of Stone and yet to have it
transformed by the power of the Gospel
MH so Ezekiel 36 and you want 26 and 27
26 and 27 I will give you a new heart
and put a new spirit within you I will
take the Heart of Stone out of your
flesh and give you a heart of Flesh
that's 26 and 27 I will put my spirit
within you and cause you to walk in my
statutes and you will keep my judgments
and do them so there is hope oh yes yes
up until the time we hear let him that
is just be be just still or him that is
unjust be unjust still up until the time
there is hope for change y yeah you know
you take for example the case of the
Apostle Paul I mean when he was Saul yes
he was a nasty character indeed he was I
mean he led to the death of many Martyrs
in fact he said I consented to the death
of your Mar
Steven act word martyr is used yes and
yet what did the Lord do with Saul of
Tarsus yeah total change of the Lord
totally changed him so so there is hope
you know Tears Don't Have to remain
tears can wheat become
tears yes they can yes because as long
as we have freedom of choice we can make
one choice or the
other uh you have that wonderful uh
section in in in in in John uh where we
have to abide in the Lord we have to
stay with the Lord John 15 we have John
15 uh 1-5 in fact a little bit more uh
we've got to we've got abide in the Lord
and abide in the Lord and abide in the
Lord so youve got to get in and you got
to stay in you know and Christ will help
you to do just that yeah I remember when
I was a kid and I've used this
illustration before uh I used to catch
butterflies and there was this National
Park in Venezuela where they had these
beautiful blue moral uh butterflies and
all different kinds of colors even with
numbers on their wings and um so I used
to go there with my parents and catch
the butterflies put them in the jar with
carbon tetrachloride see them die
instantly after after a while I wasn't
able to do it anymore but but I added
them to my collection so several years
went by without me going to that special
place and several years later I went I
had my net with me and I had my my jar
and my mounting board and everything and
I was going to catch butterflies and uh
the there was the ranger there he said
what where are you going with all those
things I said 'w you know I'm going to
catch butterflies he says no you're not
I said well several several years ago I
used to come here to catch butterflies
uh he said yes but since that time this
has been declared a national Refuge so
you can't catch butterflies you can't
kill anything that's in this National
Park uh so you know what I did there was
these blue butterflies they love bananas
so I went outside the Gate of the
national park and I threw the banana on
the ground and any butterfly that risked
going over the fence and not abiding in
the in the place became part of my
collection so that's illustration I use
of the need to abide yes in the safe
place don't venture out because when you
venture out you're in the hands of Satan
uhhuh that that explains why when we
were down in Panama together and we went
out that one day you went to a butterfly
it was kind of a walk down memory lane
for you yeah always been interested in
butterflies interesting interesting okay
we have another
question Al righty
um this person dolly wants an
explanation of Luke chap
21: 25 and
26 Luke 21 verses 25 and 26 this is
Luke's uh take on his digest on the the
end times um and um so she she wants to
know um can we explain these verses for
her so perhaps we would do well to read
them yep and then um we can sort of wait
in uh Luke 21 and um I'll pick it up at
verse 25 uh with your kind permission
yes and there shall be signs in the sun
in the moon and in the stars and on on
the earth distress of nations with
perplexity the Sea and the waves roaring
men's Hearts failing them from fear and
the expectation of those things which
are coming on the earth for the powers
of the heavens will be
shaken okay well basically um you know
these uh verses have generally been
applied
by evangelists and the Adventist Church
to the distress that exists today in
society among the Nations you know
there's distress there's turmoil among
the Nations but in the chronological
sequence of Luke chapter 21 uh this is
taking place uh immediately before the
second coming of Christ yes after the
close of probation uh you know Matthew
chapter 24 is in strict chronological
order it is and the signs and the sun
moon and stars in Matthew 24 and: 29
they take place at the end of the
tribulation at the end of the time of
trouble mhm and so this is talking about
the time when the wicked will realize
that they're lost and they will be
distressed because they realize that
they're lost when they see the sun the
signs and the sun moon and stars um I
just like to read a statement that we
find here um in um let me see great
controversy Pages um well I don't have
the exact Pages it's in the chapter um
God's people delivered people in great
controversy but Ellen White actually
refers to these verses and she applies
them to events that take place uh during
the fifth sixth and seventh plagues of
revelation after the close of probation
uh during that time as it says here
there will be signs in the sun moon and
stars those are not the same signs that
took place in 8 1780 and 1833 those are
other signs other signs right same
Heavenly Bodies but other signs M uh and
it says and
distress of nations with perplexity the
Sea and the waves
roaring and Ellen White does describe
that um uh in her writings uh taking
place at the period of the seventh
plague uh and then men's Hearts failing
them for from fear and the expectation
of those things which are coming on the
earth and then you have this very
important uh portion of verse 26 for the
powers of the heavens will be shaken be
shaken yes and what are the powers of
the heavens that are shaken well the
powers that rule the heaven are the Sun
the moon and the stars the stars and
Ellen White in early writings page 41
states that at the voice of God the sun
moon and stars will be moved out of
their places this is at the moment of
the fifth six and seventh plagues yes so
uh in context this is not talking about
uh the distress that presently exists
among nations while probation is open
it's referring to the distress among
nations when they realize that they're
lost yes by seeing the Sun Signs and the
sun moon and stars yes I think one of
the things that we need to keep in mind
is that those things that are happening
now uh at this point in Earth's history
are all still metered if I can use that
term by the grace of God because God is
still trying to win hearts and change
lives
um you hear of uh a plane crash but some
people walk away you hear of things
happening but there's there's always
this factor of God it could have been
worse because God is still trying to get
our attention and trying to save Souls
these kinds of things that are happening
close of probation don't have that
context don't have that that uh
that U that that point to them there
God's not trying to save Souls anymore
those that are going to be saved have
have been uh determined can I say so the
kinds of punishment the kinds of fear
the kinds of trauma the kinds of drama
much much worse because they're not
mitigated the the the angels are not
holding back the winds anymore uh when
it blows now it blows without mitigation
uh because there is no uh uh trying to
save Souls that has already been
determined you know in fact uh the
distress is described not in the
identical words but it's described in
Revelation 6: 14- 17 mhm uh where it
says then the sky receded as a scroll as
a scroll and of course when it says the
sky recedes as a scroll if it it rolls
up like a scroll uh the sun moon and
stars are not going to be seen it's
going to be dark uh so it says then the
sky receded as a scroll when it is
rolled up and every mountain and Island
was moved out of its place and the kings
of the Earth the Great Men the rich men
the commanders the Mighty Men every
slave and every free man h hid
themselves in the caves and in the rocks
of the mountains and said to the
mountains and rocks fall on us see
there's the distress fall on us yes and
hide us from the face of him who sits on
the throne and from the Wrath of the
lamb for the great day of his wrath has
come has come and who is able to stand
at that time uh no one is going to be
able to change sides and say Lord I'm
yours yes because it's going to be too
late so today is the day of salvation
hear his voice today that's the point
yes if you hear his voice today Harden
can you imagine my pastor my
friend the kind of scene that's going to
be when I mean everything that we take
mountains Islands the sky the Sun the
moon the skies everything thrown into
upheaval uh the kind of Terror and and
you have no Comfort because you haven't
giv your heart to the Lord uh the kind
of Terror that's going to be in the
hearts of men and women and children are
all those who who are lost for all
eternity and must go through that before
the second coming of the lord it's going
to be incredible you know um a chapter
that we don't study very frequently in
Revelation is chapter
18 where it speaks about the demise of
the capitalist system of the
world and you know there's there's I
think six different words that are used
synonymous words uh to
describe those who have lost everything
in the Battle of Life yes the word whail
is used the word cry is used the the
word shout is used to describe how those
who are lost realize that now everything
that they accumul accumulated in life
millions and billions of dollars is
worthless yes because now they're going
to they're going to perish and they're
never going to live again yes so what
use was everything that they had you
know as Jesus said what does it profit a
man if he gains the whole world MH and
loses his soul his own soul you know the
in the last couple of days we have heard
on the news about uh the richest people
in the country not paying any taxes uh
you know and you can get upset about
that if you you know I'm serving the
lord I've got to concentrate on that but
just think you've got billions and
billions of dollars that are going to
Avail you absolutely nothing mhm can't
take it with you can't buy you one day
longer on Earth and can't buy you one
second in heaven uh it's just it's just
there to have spent your life
accumulating wealth and comfort and have
and not to have gotten a hold of Jesus
not to have forged a relationship with
Jesus what an absolute waste my pastor
what a waste of time and life uh to have
all of that and it it you you might as
well throw it in the streets because you
can't do anything with it I guess you
can say enjoy it while it lasts
yes but it's not going to last a very
long time no it's not going to last a
very long time yeah you know when you
think of the fact that there are
individuals in the world that have
billions of dollars whereas there are
billions of people who don't even have
food to eat you know it's a sin it
reminds me of the parable that Jesus
told of the sheep and the goats you know
the the goats uh you know they they did
not the emphasis there is not that they
performed evil right right but what they
did with their resources they failed to
bless those who were in need yes and I
think that's uh that's you know the gist
of this question that speaks about
distress among nations uh it's
describing the the anxiety of people
when they realize that they're lost and
nothing can save them at this point yes
it's a terrible thought
it is to to to contemplate you know the
someone said I've heard this several
times if you have three pairs of shoes
in your closet you are in the top what
5% of those on planet Earth um and so
many of us have so many more than that
um in just in the my morning watch
reading this morning Ellen White was
saying how we need to really take time
to bless others to make others happy in
our presence to do what we can to make
others life joyful
therein is a reward that money cannot
buy right so you've got this whole life
you spent accumulating money some
honestly hopefully maybe some
dishonestly but it's not going to do you
any good right and when you bless others
you are the Most Blessed very true
because it's exhilarating to see you
know when when you bless someone with
the blessings that God has given you to
see the smile on their face you know to
to to to see how happy they are yes you
know that makes me
happy it is a it is a blessing so um uh
it's it's a very very very important
Point um uh basically you got to stay on
the Lord's Side you got to put it all in
the Lord's hands and uh in your getting
get wisdom and of course the fear of the
Lord is the beginning of of all wisdom
in and out in and out yes you know like
like the story of a man it's like the
story of the man who always built bigger
barns MH you know he said oh my goods
you know they've increased so much let's
build a bigger Barn yeah tear it down
big and the gist of the parable is don't
build a bigger Barn give all the stuff
away so that you have the barn to fill
again there you
go so anyway okay well we got another
question um I think the next question
has to do with the names that are given
to to Jesus you want to share that all
right is there any significance to the
name Jesus Christ as opposed to Christ
Jesus does one name Jesus emphasize his
humanity and the other uh Christ
Divinity does the order of mentioning
those names that is Jesus Christ or
Christ Jesus in scripture indicate any
emphasis on either nature of Christ and
of course they give several examples
acts 194 Romans 3:22 1 Corinthians 1:2
uh 1 Peter 4 11 uh Jesus Christ Christ
Jesus uh well uh you know I've thought
about this uh frequently I haven't done
a lot of research into it but um just on
the basis of uh of a quick
analysis uh I don't see that one is
emphasizing the Divinity of Christ and
the other is emphasizing the humanity of
Christ I think what we need to focus on
is the meaning of each of those names
there you go uh and of course what is
the meaning of Jesus and what is the
meaning of Christ uh I think both of
those are referring especially to the
humanity of Christ yes because the word
Christos Christ means the anointed one
and Jesus was anointed at his baptism
for his Earthly Ministry and of course
he he was conceived of the Holy Spirit
as well um and of course the name Jesus
you shall call his name Jesus that's the
Incarnation also yes for he he shall
save his people from their sins Matthew
so I think we need to focus more on the
meaning of the word Christ and the
meaning of the word Jesus rather than uh
trying to decipher whether the order is
correct one way or the other way yes I I
and and and my little notes here almost
be speak precisely what you just said um
I don't see them as having any
significance one on the other one of
course is the office the other name um
Jesus is savior uh Yeshua in Hebrew uh
uh Christos Christ the anointed one so
they Bes speake uh his role His function
what he came to do uh uh uh for Humanity
but I don't necessarily see them and I
wouldn't say that that that that that's
totally wrong but I don't see that
necessarily as being the primary focus
of those dream you know it's kind of
like it's kind of like in the
gospels Jesus used the expression
kingdom of God and Kingdom of Heaven yes
you know some people try to make a
distinction between the kingdom of God
and the kingdom of heaven but the
interesting thing is that in one gospel
uh where Jesus tells a parable it says
Kingdom of Heaven in another gospel the
same Parable it says kingdom of God so
so you know the the specific terminology
does not have any particular
significance uh and so I don't see the
order of names uh here having any
particular significance um it might be a
good idea for a doctoral dissertation
you
think for all the scholars who are
watching if there are any Scholars you
know I challenge you to do a
doctor on the order of the names is if
it's Jesus Christ or Christ
Jesus so anyway well I don't think we
have time for another question so I want
to take advantage of this uh moment uh
to remind you that um starting on June
21st as you know we have our anchor
School of Theology yes and this year we
are going to study uh Revelation 15
through revelation 22 and the title is
uh from the close of probation till the
new Earth and we're going to do a verse
by verse study uh we have a 421 page a
group of study notes that I wrote for
this particular class I had more fun
writing than this uh group this study
notes than any that I've done before
excellent uh because 15 to 22 you know
that's that deals with what we're going
to face in the future uh and uh so it
was very exciting to prepare this uh
these study notes yes uh you know if you
want to register you still can uh we
have two ways that you can attend either
electronically or you can come in person
the meetings are going to take place uh
here in Fresno Fresno Central Church
because we have have a larger group than
usual uh and so you can take it uh you
know online uh but you have to register
and you can also take it in person so uh
if you want to come just call our number
here at Secrets unsealed or send us an
email and uh we'll uh register you so
that you could come to this class it's
going to be a real enriching experience
you know this is exciting because
usually we try to pack them in here in
the studio and of course you got to kind
of put them kind of close together in
studio so uh you decided to move down to
the the uh Fresno Central Church so you
can kind of spread out and do what you
have to do uh and maintain you know we
want to be maintain our social
distancing that kind of thing yet still
we want to bring the people in to do so
it's a great thing it's going to be a
great study and uh we are all looking
forward forward to it we want everyone
to have peace of mind yes indeed you
know some people feel self-conscious
about being close others don't uh you
know some people want to ma wear masks
some don't M you know we respect
people's uh decisions but we want to
make everyone feel comfortable so uh
don't forget to register may God bless
you and keep you in his care until next
time uh we hope to see you next time
[Music]